I took my nine-year-old son uh who who
didn't know a lot about hockey but I
said you got to come to the Hall of Fame
with me but I said I got to put a hat
and sunglasses on if we want to get
around there's a lot of kids there they
got a great interactive part of the Hall
of Fame downstairs and my son says can
we get in line and I want to try this
and I said great so he's one for one two
for two three for three he ends up four
for five right and he goes dad will you
try this and I said yeah I'll try it I'm
0 for one 0 for two 0 for three and the
young kid who was running the line says
sir if you move your hand down the St s
a little
farther I was so mad at him I threw my
hat off and I told myself we're running
out of
here